die Ampel steht
tja was bedeutet das konkret 178
seitenampelvertrag der Deutschlandplan
für die nächsten vier Jahre also das ist
viel Stoff sehr viel Stoff um alles
genau durchzulesen Wort für Wort und er
hat es getan unser Bild Parlamentschef
Ralf Schuler Ralf schön dass du da bist
hallo ja und diese fünf kleinen Dinge
haben dich besonders groß aufgeregt wie
diese Passage zum Beispiel im
Koalitionsvertrag zum Ausländerrecht
nämlich da heißt es wir werden die
Klärung der Identität einer Ausländerin
oder eines Ausländers um die Möglichkeit
eine Versicherung an eidesstaat
abzugeben erweitern und werden hierzu
eine gesetzliche Regelung im
Ausländerrecht schaffen Ralf Schuler das
muss man sich mal klar machen es war
eine der größten Probleme in der
migrationskrise 2015 dass wir keine
Identitäten hatten von den Zugewanderten
die sie einfach weggeworfen hatten um
bestimmte Länder als Herkunftsländer
beispielsweise oder ein alter anzugeben
und die Koalition macht sich die Welt
wie sie sie gerne haben möchte und sagt
gut kann man vernünftig auch einfach
unterschreiben ich bin der und der und
ich bin so und so alt in Verbindung mit
dem neuen Zuwanderungsrecht was sie auch
einführen wollen wäre es naheliegend
dass man sich einen möglichst junges
Alter gibt weil man ab 27 dann wenn man
drei Jahre in Deutschland gewesen ist
schon ein unbegrenztes Aufenthaltsrecht
bekommt also da schneidet sich die neue
Koalition wirklich irgendwie ins eigene
Fleisch und Ralf das sagt die Ampel zum
Thema
genau und das sagte die Ampel zum Thema
Fliegen gibt es weiter Billigflieger
nach Mallorca oder alles teurer jetzt
mit den Grünen wir werden uns bei der
Europäischen Union dafür einsetzen dass
Flugtickets nicht zu einem Preis
unterhalb der Steuern Zuschläge Entgelte
und Gebühren verkauft werden dürfen
Ralph heisdorf wird teurer würde teurer
werden wenn es denn durchkäme ist so ein
bisschen wünsch dir was und sehr wolkig
gehalten man fragt sich die Ampel steht
ja aber auf welcher Farbe eigentlich da
muss man bei der Europäischen Kommission
nachfragen müssen die reguliert aber
nicht die Preise und die anderen Länder
werden sich bedanken dafür dass die
Deutschen kommen und sagen wir aber
reden bei euren flugticketpreisen mit da
wird man warten müssen was dabei
rauskommt
die Ampel steht
ja selbst übers Thema Verhütung haben
sich Scholz Lindner Habeck und bärbock
ihre Gedanken gemacht das heißt nämlich
im Koalitionsvertrag wir wollen
Krankenkassen ermöglichen
Verhütungsmittel als Satzungsleistung zu
erstatten bei geringverdienenden werden
die Kosten übernehmen übernommen also
der Staat zahlt Kondome gratis Gummis
ist immer eine gute Sache es gab ja
schon den Vorstoß die Mehrwertsteuer von
19 auf 7% zu senken bei Hygieneartikeln
jetzt also der weitere Vorstoß auch die
männliche Verhütung ins Visier zu nehmen
hochinteressant ich bin gespannt welche
Kondome da erstattet werden ob alle
bunten alle gerippten genau
mit welchen Geschmackssorten das ist
hochinteressant im Ernst es geht
natürlich darum dass
Verhütung keine Sache der Frauen ist das
kann man ja nachvollziehen und deshalb
sollen bei sozialen schwachen auch die
Kondome künftig erstattungsfähig sind ob
das wirklich funktioniert ist eine
andere Sache ist natürlich
eine seltsame Schwerpunktsetzung auf
solchen Detailfragen in einem
Koalitionsvertrag der Deutschland die
nächsten Jahre prägen soll also da ist
irgendwie mit irgendjemand ist dann das
Pferd durchgegangen das Scholz Kondom
Tollwitz die Ampel steht und es wird
noch besser was sagt die Ampel
eigentlich zum Thema Liebe zur wahren
Liebe zu ehe auch das steht nämlich drin
im Koalitionsvertrag wir werden das
Institut der
Verantwortungsgemeinschaft einführen
mann oh Mann und damit jenseits von
Liebesbeziehungen oder Ehe zwei oder
mehr volljährigen Personen ermöglichen
rechtlich füreinander Verantwortung über
zu übernehmen klingt nicht ganz nach dem
noch klassischen Familienmodell Ralf gut
die Ehe für alle hat ja ohnehin schon
eigentlich alle Möglichkeiten eröffnet
und da ist das nur konsequent wenn man
nicht mehr auf die Geschlechter abzielt
spielt die Zahl zwei auch keine Rolle
mehr wir öffnen also für eine größere
Gruppengemeinschaft ich bin gespannt wie
das wird wenn oder irgendjemand aus dem
Nahen Osten mit mehreren Frauen einreist
die viel eher war bisher in Deutschland
nicht gestattet das wird jetzt eine
Verantwortungsgemeinschaft kann man gern
so machen aber es war bislang in unserem
Kulturkreis eigentlich nicht üblich was
dahinter steckt ernsthaft gesehen ist
dass man versuchen will die
Partnerschaften von Homosexuellen die
gemeinsame Kinder haben irgendwie
zusammen zu binden und in eine
gemeinschaftsverbindung zu bringen man
öffnet damit aber natürlich einer bunten
Personengesellschaft
Tür und Tor und eigentlich ist dafür
eher das firmenrecht zuständig die
Gesellschaft mit beschränkter Haftung
die Ampel steht
und auch das hier will die Ampel Regeln
große Worte beim Thema Frauenrechte
nämlich diese gemeinsam mit unseren
Partnern wollen wir im Sinne einer
feminist Forint policy Rechte Ressourcen
und Repräsentanz von Frauen und Mädchen
weltweit stärken und gesellschaftliche
Diversität fördern das klingt wie
Vereinten Nationen reif das sind
interessanter Punkt weil auch hier
plötzlich dieser seltsame Wechsel ins
Englische erfolgt das ist nicht ganz
ohne Hintergrund die FDP hat sich
maßgeblich dagegen gestreut dass man
feministische Außenpolitik schreibt also
haben die Grünen denen man das Feld der
Gesellschaftspolitik weitgehend
überlassen hat hier das eng den
englischen Begriff gewählt man darf
gespannt sein ob Außenpolitik
funktioniert indem wir ihnen unsere
Werte in alle Welt tragen und den
Menschen in Afrika oder in anderen
Ländern mitgeben wie sie mit ihren
gesellschaftspolitischen Werten
umzugehen haben das wird ein hartes Brot
für die Außenministerin wenn sie es denn
Annalena baerbock werden sollt kann man
nur viel Erfolg wünschen